things are quiet at bagram air base
once the nerve center of america's
longest running war
a hundred thousand u.s troops were here
during the course of the past
20 years the final ones leaving quietly
on friday
the afghans are in charge now but the
question is
which afghans and for how long
shopkeepers nearby are worried about
more than their source of income
security issues affect our sales it's
not a problem for us if there are
foreign forces here or if they leave
but the fact that the taliban are taking
over the districts at any moment
affects our work
sales aren't very good most shopkeepers
won't invest in their shops because they
are worried about the country's future
and don't know what will happen they are
also worried that war will break out
other shops in the southern province of
kandahar are closing
and families leaving as the front line
approaches and what is now more clearly
a war between the afghan government and
the taliban
taliban fighters are making inroads in
kandahar after taking over abandoned
outposts the fighters
share their spoils elsewhere in kabul
province
u.s armored vehicles and weapons which
could potentially be used in the fight
against the afghan government forces
taliban are capitalizing over that
vacuum which has been created by the
withdrawal
now so that is why they have intensified
the the the
the conflict and are having
fast battlefield gains particularly in
the north of afghanistan
this will these battlefield gains will
definitely strengthen
the taliban's position in any coming
negotiations if that is to happen and as
well as this has
sent shock waves from the morale
perspective
within the government rank and fire
across the north of afghanistan
government troops have surrendered
districts without a fight
more than one thousand fled to
neighboring tajikistan on monday
that prompted tajik president emma mali
rahman to call up twenty thousand
reserve troops to the border with
afghanistan
it is quite um quite remarkable the
collapse that we have seen
um during june and now into july um
you know beyond uh beyond this is the um
the either the best expectations of the
taliban or the worst expectations of the
afghan government
and the um and the americans the
taliban's making gains every day
so where does that leave afghanistan in
the post-u.s era
andrew chappelle al jazeera